[Music]
all right john we got to talk about
something because it's on everyone's
hearts and minds and that is cars
everyone's losing their minds the car
market here up in here up in here and we
are both uh are in the market for a car
and it's a very stressful time when
you're trying to do it especially with
cash
okay so you are currently purchasing one
i did recently a few months ago
it was the strangest interaction i've
ever had
when it comes to transaction
it got to where
i wrote a check and i was looking at the
salesman and i
because it was like hey we need to like
talk to you about this and you know if
you finance it here and i said look dude
i gotta check
and it got i felt like i was talking to
my son i said i want to give you this
and i want you to give me that
thingy i have money
you have the key i can see it just give
me that and i'll give you this like well
you know we gotta we gotta go through
these meetings and i said i'm not gonna
buy any of your special clear coats i
don't want any extended warranty i just
want that could you just take this can i
just give you this can i just give you
this man it was such an event
that i ended up leaving and then we
called back and i said hey how about
this just bring it by
we literally like a mile and a half down
there just drop it off here i'll give
you this giant check for it
you would dude it was easier to buy my
house than it was to buy a car with cash
wow and you you're in the middle of it
now has it gotten worse yeah yeah i just
tried yesterday and here's the thing
okay so don't fill me in on this i'm
like literally american
article to you to prove what i'm
experiencing okay wall street journal
here's the headline car dealerships
don't want your cash oh there you go
they want to give you a loan there you
go buyers say dealerships are pushing
them to borrow because they make more
money that way the hot car market is
giving them the opportunity so every
time in history
it's if you'll pay with cash it's
actually cheaper yeah we'll get the deal
done faster and now they're charging
they're up charging you right
yes and uh the the numbers show this
john if you finance a car the dealership
makes you know three four thousand
dollars if you just pay cash
they're gonna make hundreds of dollars
maybe a thousand so they're making way
less if you pay cash they're making
money off the financing deals they can
get you to finance they get kickbacks
from the lenders they have their own
financing they're making money from that
and so it's actually increasingly
difficult to buy a car with cash now
this is not your excuse america to go
well i'm going to go get a car loan
because
it's too hard to pay with cash i'm not
going to get a discount
you still have to pay with cash you will
not go into debt for a car but here's my
experience john i said hey uh yeah i'm
not going to finance i was just straight
up with them which you know problem
number one honesty shouldn't have done
that and they go okay well it's going to
cost you a thousand dollars more
if you're going to pay in full
and i went okay well i guess you're not
getting my business then
and so i just said hey let's be clear
the check you're about to write it's a
decent size check yeah it's a good chat
yeah and so i said here's what i'm
willing to pay
you call me back if you can do that
otherwise the end of the conversation
and that's what happened and i just got
a text while we're doing the show that
was like hey
let's talk asap i've got some updates
for you and so this is the digital
version of the walk away
so here's what this comes down
and so here's what i want you to know
the person with the most patience the
most information and the most options
always wins
in any spending decision
when you're not desperate you can make a
better decision when you have options
you can make a better decision when
you're willing to walk a resource yes so
here's what i want to tell you guys do
your research there's so many avenues
online to research the exact car you
want
you will know more than the dealership
does about that car by the time you walk
in there uh number two i want you to
make sure that you know the exact value
of your trade and here's the thing if
you've got a trade-in appraise it before
you get the out the door price because
otherwise they start finagling it
on the back end they wind it down to
charge you more yeah when you say no no
you said my car's worth four thousand
that's what we're going to do here and
the out the door price includes all the
taxes and fees the doc fees all that
stuff that is the number we need to aim
at
you you don't have to say hey i'm not
going to finance today you can save that
to the end if you really want to you
know stick the knife in and go slap the
check on the table see i'm like you i'm
like hey it's a cash deal i'm going to
walk out today with this car i've
already i've already driven it i want
that one can we just not play the game
yeah they do the foursquare and they go
we can get your payments down to
whatever you want yeah not really that
kind of guy no it's cool
so here's what i want you to do go in
with a cashier's check maybe a little
bit below the asking price like here's
what i would love to pay for this car
and when they see that check in hand
they're still going to go well we can
make 26 000 right now or we can hope
that someone finances it in the next
month or get a car off our lot and get a
trade-in now if they go above that cash
cashier's check and you still feel like
it's a good deal
that's okay you can supplement that with
your own check with cash whatever that
looks like so you don't need the exact
number
on the table there and i do think it's
important to call it here so
there's a whole bunch of car dealerships
trying to do right by people
um some good guys there's a great guy
larry and paducah that's a lot of our
people here at ramsey do business with
great human being that's trying to help
people out trying to put them in cars
and so this isn't all car dealerships
are bad and i hadn't bought a car in a
long time and it used to be they put
something in the paper i don't know if
you remember what that those days were
like but or they put something online
and then you go haggle i do understand
now like after talking with the guys and
getting some more information that the
buying a car is different now the the
idea you're gonna go in and get eight
thousand dollars off those days are not
here yes right so
as a buyer don't be a jerk don't be a
[ __ ] don't squeeze the um yeah i'm
gonna be kind be a good human being yeah
say this is what i can afford to pay i
want that car let's make it let's shake
hands and then if you can't walk out the
door yes but agreeing on that out the
door price is the key yeah because if
you agree on that then it doesn't matter
what they say about financing no we
agreed this is the price of the car and
please please look at the contract and
if there's anything beyond a small doc
fee and your sales tax for the state
county you live in
run if they're trying to tack on all
these extra things and warranties they
force walk out of there well i'm not
paying anything but a small doc fee and
if you can get rid of that that's even
better and then the taxes which yes we
have to pay our taxes on these on sales
tax on these cars yeah so do that walk
in with a cashier's check don't walk in
with a barrel full of cash of actual
physical dollars that is a terrible move
it's dangerous they've got to report it
to the irs they don't want to deal with
that hassle so yes we say pay cash we
don't actually mean take a briefcase
like it's a you know an old old-school
movie it's kind of baller though
it is i've known people who've done it
and they get laughed out of there they
go go get a cashier's check we're not
gonna we're not playing that game
so
be patient do your research know your
options don't go on a saturday when it's
packed out go at the end of the month on
a weeknight when it's not raining so
that you can actually do the inspection
and not be in a rush and that's gonna
help you make the best financial
decision and be willing to sacrifice i
know you wanted this exact specification
it's okay if you've got another option
you're desperate
then you got to deal with that but
here's the other thing don't buy a car
right now unless you absolutely have to
yeah don't buy a car
get a fix
that's right james gets it
now ken and i took uh
ken and i took a call about a snosberry
jeep and the wife really wanted this
exact jeep color was the only
one to get and we had to talk her off
the ledge and i was like snozzberry is
not even a color let's not pretend that
you need this exact jeep at this exact
time that's like a willy wonka candy bar
isn't it yeah
exactly it's from willy wonka snozzberry
very stressful stuff i'm in james did we
hit everything in this article i was
gonna say what about private sale
private sale let's talk about private
sale john this is very important as well
okay that is when you can actually
negotiate is with a private sale you can
get more money if you're selling that
way and you can actually negotiate
because if i'm just going to john he's
got no incentives from the financing
lenders
to make money he needs money he just
wants the money he wants to sell his car
so i would be on facebook marketplace
looking for these there's some
third-party sites like auto trader where
people are just listing their cars for
sale so that's where i would start my
research and see if i can work it out
and always always get an inspection on
the car from a mechanic this will cost
you about a hundred bucks but no matter
who's selling it go get an inspection
from a reputable mechanic before you go
slap 10 grand down because it's a deal
and then you find out there are some
major issues that you didn't know about
until you're going over 60 on the
interstate and it starts rattling
right transmission falls yes so you've
got to do the inspection negotiate with
cash in hand be a kind person commit say
hey i've got cash today if you can do
this deal i'll show up
and so that uh that's how to navigate
this market john it's not fun i totally
feel empathy for people that really need
a car and you can find a car by the way
that's under fifteen thousand dollars
under ten thousand we get a lot of flack
for that people go you can't phone a car
you can't beat your cars they don't
exist go to auto trader wherever and do
sort by lowest price there's some great
cars for four or five thousand dollars
three thousand dollars suck it up no
one's gonna stop you in a parking lot
and be like
yeah i want some of this no it's not
that kind of car been stopped but it'll
get you where you need to go that's
right